wanna be happy live a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some of the best
jordan peterson motivation enjoy
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing right so it's
it's a fairly it's a fairly limited
attempt first of all we're not going to
say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense
but we will presume that there are
things that you're doing that for one
reason or other you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop
they're kind of self-evident to you
other things you're going to be doubtful
about you're not going to know which way
is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or
you don't believe it's necessary or it's
too much of a sacrifice or
you're angry or resentful or or afraid
who knows
so forget about those for now but
there's another
subset that you could stop doing it
might be little thing
well that's fine stop doing it and see
what happens
and what'll happen is your vision will
clear a little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of
apprehension that you will also know you
should stop doing
and that you could stop doing because
you strengthened yourself a bit by
stopping doing the particular stupid
thing that you were doing before
that just puts you together a little bit
more and you could do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and
and you know that doesn't necessarily
mean that you're going to ever be able
to formulate a clear
and final picture of what constitutes
the truth and the good
but it does mean that you'll be able to
continually move away from what's
untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start make
a
schedule and stick to it okay so what's
the rule with the schedule
it's not a bloody prison that's the
first thing that people do wrong they
say well i don't like to
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up
well i have to do this then i have to do
this then i have to do this
you know and then i just go play video
games because who wants to do all these
things that i have to do
it's like wrong set the schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow
if i was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day i could have
practically speaking what would it look
like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any
sense one of the things that you're
going to insist upon is that at the end
of the day
you're not in worse shape than you were
that than at the beginning of the day
right because that's a
day if you have a bunch of those in a
row you just dig you know you dig
yourself a hole and then you bury
yourself in it's like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are
but even that you can you can ask
yourself okay well i've got these
responsibilities
i have to schedule the damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you gotta
work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
gonna do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know
so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank
man but you know you have to negotiate
with yourself and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 percent accuracy but
that beats that out of zero right and if
you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for god's sake or
because you're you're going to hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward
i know you stated in the last um uh
lecture that the importance for setting
aims in life
and to kind of have
goals to work towards right so my
question was
um where do you how do you do that if
you don't know where you want to go
because
that's kind of where i got stuck on your
your future authoring program
because okay that's that's a good
question that's a really good question
so there's this notion in the old
testament that morality is
following a sequence of prohibitions
there's a bunch of bad things you
shouldn't do
and then basically you're good enough
and and and i think there's wisdom in
that i think that's kind of where
children start right you
i mean i love children and all that but
they're they're they're crazy little
creatures and they need to be
you know civilized and partly what you
do is you
you lay prohibitions on them and mostly
what you're trying to do is
lay prohibitions on them for the
behaviors that if they manifested would
make their life
miserable so this is why this thing that
i've said to people has become this
crazy internet meme but that's to clean
up your room
and which which is a lot better and more
useful than people think it's a lot
harder too but
the the thing the first thing you do i
think and i learned this in part from
solzhenitsyn when he was trying to iron
out his soul when he was in the gulag
because he was trying to figure out how
he got there
how he contributed to how he got there
you know not stella
and hitler even though they were kind of
to blame you know but there was much he
could do about that
i think what you have to do and this is
part of humility is you have to look
around you
within your sphere of influence like the
direct sphere of influence
and fix the things that announce
themselves as
in need of repair and those are often
small things
you know and they can be like your room
put it in order because the thing is it
isn't exactly so important that your
room is in order although it is
what's important is that you learn how
to distinguish between chaos and order
and to be able to act in a manner that
produces when people
are beset with a catastrophe like let's
say the death of their father
that they are prone to use that as an
excuse for not going about the business
that they should be going about
because they can say to themselves well
i would accept
and accept there's always good reasons i
mean believe me there's always good
reasons for not doing what you should
that's for sure the reasons pile up day
after day to not do what you should
especially because you're you're aiming
at things in the future you can put them
off indefinitely right
because of the demands of the day
there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at
what it is that you should be doing it's
absolutely reprehensible
to justify your inaction with a
catastrophe that extracts
mercy from other people right there's a
tricky
tricky game that's going well of course
i can't do that look at the terrible
thing that's just happened to me and say
okay i understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current catastrophe
it's like well actually you're not and
it's rather rude of you to use it as an
excuse
and it's certainly counterproductive
sometimes you know
i can't sleep at night because i'm
thinking about something and usually
what i'll do is go
write it down i have some writing to do
so i get up and i go write down what i'm
thinking and that usually does the trick
but because i had been playing with
youtube i thought
well i'll try making youtube video and
and
telling people what i'm thinking about
and and see if that
performs the same uh function as
writing and to me the function of
writing well it's twofold one is
conceivably to communicate with people
although
the fundamental purpose for me is to
clarify my thoughts so that i know
to you know because if you're if
something is disturbing you
what that means is that it needs to be
articulated it what it's the emergence
of unexplored territory
something that disturbs you that that's
the right way to think about it it's
unmapped territory that's manifesting
itself
it's like a vista of threat and
possibility and you need to articulate a
path through it
and so that's what i was doing it's like
i was thinking well this is bothering me
and this seems to be why and here's what
i think is going on and
and so i made the videos and in some
sense i i didn't think
anything more of it you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine but it's not
a hopeless doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a motive
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned
is by well certainly by the avoidance of
deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your
part to actually rectify them and the
thing that's so interesting about that
is
that well two as far as i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals
if you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid of
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that are
because
you might ask yourself like if for 10
years if you didn't avoid
doing what you knew you needed to do by
the deaf by your own definitions right
within the value structure that you've
created
to the degree that you've done that what
would you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do
find out over decades long periods what
they could be like if they were who they
were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward and they get stronger and
stronger and stronger and we don't know
the limits to that we do not know the
limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably
can be left at your feet because you're
not everything you could be and you know
it
and of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider
but there's real promise in it right
because it means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could
act in the world so what it would
reflect back to you would be much better
than what it reflects back to you now
my experience is with people that we're
probably running at about 51
of our capacity something you can think
about this yourselves
i often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste and
the classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day
you know inefficient studying watching
things on youtube
that not only do you not want to watch
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching after
you're done
that's probably four hours right there
you know you think well that's
20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours a
month that's two and a half full work
weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50
if you think about it in terms of
deferred wages if you're wasting
20 hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year
and you are doing that right now and
it's because you're young wasting 50 000
a year is a way bigger catastrophe than
it would be for me to waste it because
i'm not going to last nearly as long
and so if your life isn't everything it
could be you could ask yourself well
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient
20 times more efficient that's the
pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get
it's completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop
making things worse because that's
another thing people do all the time
not only do they not do what they should
to make things better
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful
or arrogant or deceitful or or homicidal
or genocidal or
all of those things all bundled together
in an absolutely pathological package
if people stopped really really trying
just to make things worse
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential
system of ideas between human
vulnerability
social judgment both of which are are
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility
that they know they should adopt it
isn't merely that
your fate depends on whether or not you
get your act together and
to what degree you decide that you're
going to live
out your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's 9 billion 7 billion people in
the world we're going to peak at about 9
billion by the way
and then it'll decline rapidly but 7
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust mote
among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's
simply not the case it's the wrong model
because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life
and they'll know a thousand people each
and that puts you one person away from a
million
and two persons away from a billion and
so that's how you're connected and the
things you do
they're like dropping a stone in a pond
the ripples move outward
and they affect things in ways that you
can't fully comprehend and it means that
the things that you do and that you
don't do are far more important than you
think and so if you act that way of
course the terror of realizing that is
that it actually
starts to matter what you do and you
might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter
but i mean if you really ask yourself
would you be so sure if you had the
choice
i can live with no responsibility
whatsoever the price i pay is that
nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters but i have to take the
responsibility that's associated with
that
it's not so obvious to me that people
would take the meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe maybe you've just allowed
them to collapse because it's
a lot easier than acting them out and
the price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are when the
alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well
what solzhenitsyn figured out and so
many people in the 20th century it's not
just him even though he's the best
example
is that if you live a pathological life
you pathologize your society and if
enough people do that then
it's really
really and you can read the gulag
archipelago if you
have the fortitude to do that and you'll
see exactly what it's like
and then you can decide if that's a
place you'd like to visit
or even more importantly if it's a light
if it's a place you'd like to visit
and take all your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century
psychologists have been
not all psychologists obviously but the
psychological profession is neck deep in
this
in this pathology has been beating the
self-esteem drum for 50 years oh no
you're okay you should feel good about
yourself like
you're you're fine the way you are it's
like you think well that's a calming
message for people it's like no it's not
it's not at all and i watch my audiences
it's like it's full of people in the
audience who think
i'm suffering a lot more than i think is
tenable a whole bunch of it's my fault
my life is not
in the order it should be i know i'm
doing 50 things wrong it's like what the
hell is wrong with me what's wrong with
the people around me this is really
serious
and some you know well-meaning person
comes up and says you know you're okay
just the way you are it's like
no one wants that message it's like no
i'm not okay the way i am
i'm not okay at all the way i am i know
that and so
you know when i'm when i'm speaking to
to
when i'm speaking now i say to people
well well you're nowhere near what you
could be
that's that's the positive message it's
like yeah you're a mess but
you don't have to stay that way if
you're a mess you know it obviously
you're suffering away like
like so much you can barely tolerate it
it's like that's okay
you could do something about it if
you're hungry and you eat
well that's good but it's over and then
you're on to the next thing right
it's not exactly sustaining it's just
necessary that's called consumatory
reward by the way
this other reward system is incentive
reward and the incentive reward system
works on
dopamine this neurochemical dopamine
which is also the neurochemical tracts
that
opiates and cocaine and amphetamines the
drugs that people really like to abuse
alcohol often for some people
activate and so you might say if you
don't have enough meaning in your life
then you're more prone to
addiction and that's definitely the case
even with rats if you take a rat you put
him in a cage by himself and he has
nothing to do
and then you give him access to cocaine
he'll get addicted to the point where he
won't do anything but take cocaine
but if you throw the rat back in with a
bunch of other rats and he gets to do
rat things
then it's very hard to get him addicted
to cocaine and so the purposeless rat is
prone to addiction well it's the same
with human beings
now here's a corollary to that which is
really cool so
the magnitude of the reward you
experience as you're moving towards a
goal
is proportionate to the importance of
the goal
so that means the more important the
goal you pick the more possibility there
is for
the kind of reward let's say it's really
a state of being
that is life affirming and it is
directly life affirming in that
you know like if you're in a football
game and you're and it's an important
football game and
maybe you break a finger and you know
normally that's that's a problem it
hurts and you're going to stop doing
whatever you're doing but if you're
right in the middle of the game
then you'll be so amped up on this
reward system that it's analgesic it
stops the pain it also
suppresses anxiety so if you
have a purpose then it's analgesic
it takes some of the pain out of life
it's very positive in that it motivates
and energizes you and focuses you and
makes you able to remember and pay
attention
and it it quells fear and so those
things are all
direct and so then you might think well
what's the best possible goal
well and that's that's the purpose i
would say of religious training and
philosophical training it's like just
what
are you doing in the world rule eight
tell the truth
or at least don't lie yeah well it's not
that easy to tell the truth because who
knows about the truth but
you can learn not to say things that you
know to be false and if you stop saying
things that you know to be false then
your life will improve a lot
it simplifies it and it puts you in
alignment with reality and
you should be in alignment with reality
because there's a lot more of it than
there is of you
many times in life people don't get what
they want and they need because they
don't aim at it
and it's a hard lesson for people to
learn because they're cynical to begin
with and they presume that there's no
possible way
of moving forward but
it's not so unreasonable to assume that
you're not going to hit what you don't
aim
at or you're not going to hit what you
aim at and don't shoot at
and i've seen time and time again that
if people
do put forward a vision for what
they regard as worthy of pursuit
which is something you have to determine
in dialogue with yourself
it's like given the difficult
preconditions of existence
is there anything that you could
conceive of that you would regard as
sufficiently worthwhile so that you
would be
motivated to pursue it it's a
it's a it's a profound philosophical
question
and it's not an unreasonable one it's
it's a good place to start it's like
well life is difficult and enough to
make you cynical and bitter and
perhaps enough to make you cynical and
bitter and suicidal
and homicidal and even genocidal
and it's not surprising in some sense
and then the
question is well is there something that
you can pursue
that allows that to be
[Music]
acceptable or perhaps even desirable
which is something to do that justifies
the suffering
and it's hard to say what that would be
for each of you
it's something that you can discover
this is partly why nietzsche was wrong
nietzsche thought that after god had
died
that human beings would have to invent
their own values
but the psychoanalysts i would say jung
foremost among them
put forward a very powerful counter
claim which was that
while you can't invent values they're
already built into you
you have to discover them and i think
that's true for each person
it's like well what would justify you in
in the abandonment of your resentment
and hostility the next best predictor of
lifetime success is conscientiousness
well so and of tho of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say
orderliness and and industriousness the
better predictor is industriousness
so the question is well what can you do
about your industriousness
and the answer to that is well that's
kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits
this is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes i think the
best thing you can do with regards to
your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that
and basically it does a situational
analysis of
it helps you do a situational analysis
of your life more than a psychological
analysis i would say and so
the questions are something like well
all right you're gonna have to put some
effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so
what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship
if you're disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation
that you could draw on that you could
tailor to your own you know your own
personality
but then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across and so
we ask people about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself
properly you know what would you want
from your friendships what would you
want from your intimate relationship how
would you like to structure your family
what do you want for your career well
how are you going to use your time
outside of your
job and how are you going to regulate
your mental physical
mental and physical health and maybe
also your drug and alcohol use because
that's
that's a good place to auger down you
know because alcoholism for example
wipes out you know five to ten percent
of people so you want to keep that under
control
and then and then so maybe you know you
you you develop a vision of what your
life what you would like your life to be
and that associates the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down
the goal into micro processes that you
can implement
the microprocessors become rewarding in
proportion
in relation to their uh causal
association with the goal
and that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward
and the way it works is that it works
better if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation
working out and so the more valuable the
goal in principle the more the micro
processes associated with that goal
start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go
and so as far as i can tell what you do
is you specify
your long-term ideal maybe you also
specify a place you want to stay the
hell away from so that you're terrified
to fail as well as excited about
succeeding because that's also useful
you specify your goal you do that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want
you want to specify goals that make you
say oh
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts it would clearly be
worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy
the question is why would you ever do
anything and the answer that has to be
because you've determined
by some means that it's worthwhile and
then the next question might be well
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be well you could
consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends like you don't need to have
all these things but you better have
most of them
family friends career educational goals
plans for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you so
so once you but once you set up that
that goal structure
let's say and that's really in many in
many ways that's what you should be
doing at universities is that's exactly
what you should be doing is trying to
figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
you use everything you learn
as a means of building that person that
you want to be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly and this is
back down to the micro routine analysis
so i'm saying well you're going to try
to make yourself more industrious
okay number one specify your goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure
so if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy which is real easy because that's
just a matter of not doing as well
then you don't know when you fail and
people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful
so i'll keep myself blind about when i
fail that's fine except you'll fail all
the time then
you just won't know it until you've
failed so badly that you're done
and that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
so so i would recommend that you don't
let that happen
so that's willful blindness right you
could have known but you chose not to
okay so once you get your goal structure
set up you think okay if i could have
this
life it looks like that might be worth
living despite the fact that it's going
to be
you know anxiety provoking and
threatening and there's going to be some
suffering and loss involved in all of
that
obviously the goal is to to have a
vision for your life
such that all things considered that
justifies your effort
i started to pay very careful attention
to what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing that
has happened to them
after they've listened to some of the
material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
split into two let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me
that was talking a lot and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging and the part that
was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've
and that was happening to like 95 of
what i was saying and so then i didn't
really know what to do i thought okay
this is strange so
maybe i've fragmented and that's just
not a good thing at all
i mean it wasn't like i was hearing
voices or anything like that i mean
it wasn't like that it was it was
well people have multiple parts so then
i had a
this weird conundrum is like well which
of those two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's you're doing
that to impress
people you're just trying to win the
argument you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal
verbal business me and i didn't know but
i decided i would go with the critic
and then what i'd tried to do what i
learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk whether or not the
words that i'm saying are either making
me align or making me come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment
is i think alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because i think if
you say things that are
as true as you can say them let's say
then
they come up they come out of the depths
inside of you because
we don't know where thoughts come from
we don't know how far down into your
substructure the thoughts emerge we
don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak
from the core of your being we don't
understand any of that we don't even
conceptualize that but i believe that
you can feel that and
i learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
uh because he talked about mental health
in part as a coherence between the
the the spiritual or the or the abstract
and the physical that the two things
were aligned
and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing
not saying things that would make me
weak and what happened was that i
had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying
i would say ninety-five percent of it as
i have a shock to wake up and
i mean this was over a few months but
it's of a shock to wake up and realize
that
you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock you know and you might
think well do you really want all of
that to burn off it's like well there's
nothing left but a little husk five
percent of you it's like well
if that five percent is solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen adopt
the mode of authentic being
and that is something like refusing to
participate in
the lie in deception in the lie to
orient your speech as much as you can
towards the truth and to take
responsibility for your own life and
perhaps also for the lives of other
people
and there's something about that that's
meaningful
and responsible and noble but also
serves to mitigate the very suffering
that
produces say the nihilism or the flea
into the arms of flea
or or the or the escape into the arms of
totalitarians to begin with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability
if you configure your life so that what
you are
genuinely doing is aiming at the highest
possible
good then the things that you need to
to survive and to thrive on a day-to-day
basis
will deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because it what
it basically says is
if you dare to do the most difficult
thing that you can conceptualize
your life will work out better than it
will if you do anything else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a kierkegaardian
leap of faith there's no way you're
going to find out whether or not that's
true unless you do it
so no one no one can tell you either
because
just because it works for someone else i
mean that's interesting and all that but
it's no proof that it'll work for you
you have to be all in in this game there
is no more effective
way of operating in the world than to
conceptualize the highest good that you
can
and then strive to attain it there's no
more practical pathway to the kind of
success that you
could have if you actually knew what
success was
the world shifts itself around
your aim because you're you're a
creature that has a name
you have to have a name in order to do
something you're an aiming creature
you look at a point and you move towards
it
it's built right into you and so you
have a name well let's say your aim is
the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you it organizes all of your
perceptions it organizes what you see
and you don't see it organizes your
emotions and your motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is
the day manifests itself as a set of
challenges and problems
and if you solve them properly then you
stay on the pathway towards that ape
and you can concentrate on the on the on
the day and so that way you get to have
your cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's that
makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize
well that's the very definition of the
meaning that would sustain you in your
life
this circumambulation that jung talked
about was this
continual will return to this this
continual
circling in some sense of who you could
be you might notice for example that
there are themes in your life you know
when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself
and there might be variation on it like
a musical theme but it's
it's like you're circling yourself and
getting closer to yourself
as you move across time that's the
circumambulation now
you remember that for a second we'll go
back to it okay so imagine that
something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning
and you decide well first of all you're
paralyzed you think well how do i know
if i should pursue that it's probably a
stupid idea
and the proper response to that is
you're right it probably is a stupid
idea
because almost all ideas are stupid and
so
the the probability that as you move
forward on your adventure that you're
going to get it right the first time
is zero it's just not going to happen
and so then you might
think well maybe i'll just wait around
until i get the right idea
and which people do right so they're
like 40 year old 13 year olds which is
not a good idea
so they wait around until it's waiting
for godot until
they finally got it right but the
problem is you're too stupid to know
when you've got it right so
waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it
the perfect opportunity manifested
itself to you
in your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero
you might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere
highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's nietzsche called
that a will will to stupidity
which i really liked so because he
thought of stupidity as being it
you know it's it's you have to take it
into account fundamentally
and work with it and so and so you can
take these tentative steps
on your pathway to destiny and you can
assume that you're going to do it badly
and that's really useful because you
don't have to beat yourself up it's
pretty easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all
so you you start your path and you think
that you're heading you know towards
your star
and so you go in that direction and then
because you're here the world looks a
particular way but then when you move
here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so
what that means is that now that thing
that glimmers in front of you is going
to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at
specifying it to begin with and now that
you're a little sharper
and more focused than you were it's it's
going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you
and so then you have to take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal
but it isn't because you know you've i
mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that
far but that's a lot farther than
you would be if you just stayed where
you were waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn
what you shouldn't keep doing and if you
learn
enough about what you shouldn't keep
doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress
the degree of overshooting starts to
decline right
and that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that
as you learn a new skill like even to
play play a song on the piano for
example you overshoot madly you're
making all sorts of mistakes to begin
with and then
the mistakes
they they disappear i'm incredibly
nervous to uh
talk in front of you because you've got
to be one of the most formidable people
that i've ever
heard of or ever listened to or ever
seen so
my question is again you're one of the
best communicators that i've ever
listened to
if i could be half as good
at you or at communicating as you are
i would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice you know really like
well there's a couple of things is it
helps to read
a lot it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day 15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so
if you this is often difficult for
beginning lectures at university because
they'll do a lecture on a topic but they
only know as much as they're saying in
the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you
are saying in the lecture and then you
can specify a stepping path through it
and elaborate with the other things that
you know but to do that you have to do a
lot of reading
but you also have to do a lot of reading
because that's where the synthesize
that's where the synthesizing comes so
that's on the input side and then on the
output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say is
like if you're speaking in front of a
group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you
present to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals and you
talk to them
so when i talk to a group i always talk
to people one at a time
and that makes it easier too because you
know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating
but there isn't a thousand people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and
you can tell if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or
maybe they're asleep in which case you
look at someone else
and they they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so
one thing is to to have something to say
yeah but the next thing is pay attention
to who you're talking to
because unless you're very badly
socialized and that seems unlikely in
your case because you know you present
yourself
at least moderately well you know and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but in first but on first
sight you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience
that's a really bad way of thinking
about you're actually engaged in a
conversation with an audience even if
they're not
talking they're nodding and shifting
position and
you know looking like this or and you
can
you can pull all that in and and and use
it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well
i could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education
there isn't anything that you can
possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do
than to learn how to communicate i don't
care if you're going to be a carpenter i
mean being a carpenter by the way is
very difficult especially if you're a
good carpenter but
if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so the and this is something that the
liberal arts
colleges i think i don't know if they've
forgotten it but they don't do a very
good job of marketing it's like what's
the use of a bachelor's degree a
bachelor of arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak
you've read something it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that i've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very
very good at articulating themselves and
so whenever they negotiate
they're successful well that's kind of
like the definition of success in life
right
you negotiate and you're six doesn't
mean you win because if you're a good
negotiator
if you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation
thrilled and so then people line up to
do things with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice the best thing you can do is
teach people to write
because there's no difference between
that and thinking and one of the things
that just blows me away about
universities
is that no one ever tells students why
they should write something
it's like well you have to do this
assignment well why are you writing
well you need the grade it's like no you
need to learn to
think because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world
thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake and those could be battles for
good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
when i can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you can
possibly provide someone with
and i mean i know lots of people who've
been staggeringly successful and watched
them throughout my life i mean
those people you don't want to have an
argument with them they'll just slash
you into pieces
and they're not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're going to make your point
and they're going to make their point
you better have your points organized
because otherwise you're going to look
like and be an absolute idiot
you are not going to get anywhere and if
you can formulate your arguments
coherently
and make a presentation if you can speak
to people if you can lay out a proposal
god people give you money they give you
opportunities
you have influence if you're harmless
you're not virtuous you're just
harmless you're like a rabbit a rabbit
isn't virtuous
it's just you just can't do anything
except get eaten
it's not virtuous if you're a monster
and you don't act monstrously then
you're virtuous
but you also have to be a monster well
you see this all the time harry potter's
like that too
it's like he's he's flawed he's hurt
he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man
he breaks rules all the time all the
time he's not
obedient at all but you know he has a
good reason for breaking the rules
and if if he couldn't break the rules
him and his little clique of
rule-breaking
you know troublemakers if they didn't
break the rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal so
it's very peculiar but it's it's very
very it's a very very
very very common mythological notion
you know the hero has to be
the hero has to be a monster but a
controlled monster batman is like that
you know i mean it's it's everywhere
it's
it's the story you always hear compare
yourself to who you were yesterday and
not to who
someone else is today because if you're
comparing yourself to someone else
i mean first of all you don't know very
much about the life of the person you're
comparing yourself to you don't know it
you know it across all of its dimensions
and second people are very different and
so comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful i guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more
singular and more particular it becomes
increasingly less
useful better to compare yourself to a
previous version of yourself and work
for improvement in that way
when i was 25 or so i probably weighed
about 138 pounds i
smoked like pack cigarettes day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and
you know there were long winters there
and my friends were heavy drinkers and
most of them
dropped out of school by the time they
were 15 or 16 went off to work on the
oil rigs and
you know it was a rough town and we
drank a lot
i started when i was 14 and you know um
and so i was i had a lot of bad habits
let's say
and uh things that were and i wasn't in
great shape physically
and i was also still intellectually
obsessed by
as i am now and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i
but i decided around that about 85 84
something like that maybe a little
earlier that i was really going to try
to get my act together
and uh so i started doing that i
you know i first of all i i quit smoking
well that took a long time because i
eventually had to quit drinking too in
order to quit smoking and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done
you know i don't regret that i had a
fine time when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined i had
to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them
really you know obsessively since i was
probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that got to the point
around 25 when i was in graduate school
trying to get my phds doing all my
research like i published 15 papers by
the time i
graduated with my phd which was by i
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any un
graduate student at that time had ever
published at mcgill i think that's right
might have been twice as many or maybe
twice as many maybe even three times as
many and at the same time i wrote maps
of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because i was writing about
three hours a day doing that and
i couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my
sort of my what would you say my
my my hedonistic my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up
and also work seriously on the issues
that were at hand so
you know i had to stop that's a
sacrifice i had to stop
messing about and straight myself out
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because
you know people play a role in their own
demise so to speak
when you had opportunity to go out and
explore
or withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid
so it's not only that you were
overprotected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity
you know so maybe you're a kid in the
playground right and you're having some
trouble with other kids
and you know in the back of your mind i
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene
and you know that that's not right you
know that you're breaking the social
contract
but it's easier and so that's what you
do you run off to an authority figure
and hide behind the great father right
roughly speaking well the problem with
that is you don't learn how to do it
yourself
so then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40.
so then you take people out you say well
what are you afraid of rank it from 1 to
10.
so 10 is make a list of 10 things you're
afraid of
the least the thing you're least afraid
of we'll call number 10.
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's
how you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest proximity you can
manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death
that's what you've learned and then you
move a little closer and then you move a
little closer and then you move a little
closer and finally you're back in
what's no longer the elevator from a
symbolic perspective it's a tomb right
it's
it's it's a place of enclosure and
isolation
and you learn turns out i can withstand
that
and then you're met much more together
much more confident
and that's often one of the things that
often happens in situations like that
i've seen this multiple times
is that if you run someone through an
exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often
start standing up to people around them
in a way they never did before
well the first thing i think you need to
understand is that these people that
you're comparing yourself to you don't
really know
very well you know and um
what that means is that you see they're
shiny outside but you don't see the
reality of their life
and so what you're
you know maybe you're in california see
someone speeding down the road in a
in a convertible portion you think oh
man what a lucky bastard and
um the truth of the matter is that he's
thinking about wrapping his
expensive sports car around the next
cement pillar that he comes
close to you know you you can't tell and
people have hard lives
and and even people who are
comparatively fortunate have hard lives
and
so the the ideal
that you're observing that makes you
jealous and resentful
is in large part an illusion that's
created by your own mind
and i
[Music]
you know i i can give you just one
example is like i know a fair number of
extremely wealthy people and
um most of them most of the people i
happen to know are people who've made
them their money themselves
and i tell you man they have a burden of
responsibility that
would would crush me would
would crush the typical person they're
just working
flat out like 90 hours a week
and they have thousands of people
depending on them and you know they have
their money
and and they have their status and
that's not nothing
but don't be thinking that there isn't a
price to be paid for that you know they
don't see their families they're often
divorced they don't see their children
grow up
and and they don't have time off
now there are wealthy
what would you call playboy types i
suppose who
live out the dreams of wealth of a
foolish 14 year old but
they're not that common and you have to
be careful of what you're jealous of
because you don't really know what it is
and then the other thing that's kind of
useful is to
well to understand that you're different
from everyone else and
this is especially true as you get older
when when you're 17 or 16 or something
like that
comparing yourself to other people makes
a certain amount of sense because
16 and 17 year olds they're kind of the
same you know which is why
when you go off to university you can
make friends so quickly it's like
i'm i'm just about 60. it takes me like
15 years to make a friend now
you know as opposed to the two months
that it took when i was 17.
um you're you're quite different from
other people and
you shouldn't be comparing yourself to
them because they're not like you
you know they don't have your family
they don't have your temperament they
don't have your troubles
they don't have your abilities the only
person that
[Applause]
the only the only person that has those
is you
and this is why one of the rules i think
it's rule four
is compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today
and see that's a game you can win
because
you could be a little better today than
you were yesterday
and that's a good thing you're a little
better that that's a good thing
and you know no doubt there are some
things that you could improve
you know if you if you sit and meditate
for any length of time about
what you're not doing optimally but you
have to be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low
especially in those places where you're
not functioning well
and it might be so embarrassing that you
can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
fathom that that's actually
who you are but you know jung
described the fool the archetypal figure
of the trickster and the fool as the
precursor to the savior to the redeemer
and that's unbelievable bit of wisdom
because
what you meant was that to put yourself
together
which is to follow the path of
redemption
to follow the redeemer if the redeemer
is a type of personality that you could
in fact
be inhabited by or manifest then
this first step towards that is to allow
yourself to be a fool
right it's because you
you don't know what you're doing you
have to admit that and
there's going to be a loss of ego or
destruction of ego
arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that
but you need the loss of that arrogant
ego because it's precisely what's
interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process
mythologically speaking that stops moral
progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice
what you're like so that you could
change properly you don't want to
sacrifice that part of yourself
it's probably associated with some
delusion that
helps you maintain in
what you say a positive although very
fragile self-image
you know in the absence of genuine
effort if you concentrate solely on your
career
you can get a long way in your career
and i would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially
do that that's all they do they work
like 70 80 hours a week
they go flat out on their career they're
staking everything on the
small probability of exceptional status
in a narrow domain
but it's it's hard on them they don't
have a life it's very difficult for them
to have a family
they don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very
one-dimensional now
it may be that that unit dimensionality
is the price you have to pay to be
exceptional at one thing
right because if you're going to be
something like a genius level
mathematician
and you want to do that for or a
scientist say it's like
you're in your lab you're in your lab
all the time you're working 70 hours a
week or 80 hours a week you're smart
you're dedicated you're uni-dimensional
and that's how you get to beat
all the other people who are doing that
it's the only way
but the problem is you don't get a life
now if you love being a scientist and
you have that kind of focus of mind
well first of all you're a rare person
and second you're going to pay for it
but fine more power to you but
but it's a it's a risky business to do
that
you sacrifice a lot for it you know and
i would say
most often if you're speaking about
having a healthy life
that isn't what you do you spread
yourself out more so you know you have a
family
you have some things that you do outside
of work that are meaningful to you and
useful
you you have a network of friends um
well that those three things alone are
four things alone or
plenty to keep you well oriented and
then if one of those things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now
the price you pay for that is the more
you strive to optimize that balance
the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them
but you might have a very you know if
you could consider your life as a whole
that might be a winning strategy it was
the night it was the night before we
were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and
he had put in all the plastic piping you
know and i was going to test the joints
they're supposed to be glued together
with this pipe glue right
and i said i told him i had to test the
joints and he said well you don't have
to test my joints they never leak and i
thought yeah that's okay
how about if i test them so i went up on
the third floor and filled the pipes
with water
capping them in the basement like you're
supposed to and like half an hour later
i had two inches of water in the
basement
there were 30 leaking joints that was
the night before the drywallers were
supposed to show up
so well so he wasn't particularly
competent that's the point of that story
but even more so
he had put a bunch of the plastic pipe
outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night
you know sawing through plastic pipe and
re-gluing joints so that
my well so that the dry rollers could
come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause
trouble we don't need people to cause
more trouble we need people to solve
problems you know and so you can be a
tradesman and you can be you can make a
lot of money as a tradesperson it's a
bloody
reliable honorable uh forthright
productive way of making a living and
there is a hell of a lot of difference
between a working man who knows what
he's doing
and one who doesn't both in terms of
skill and ethics
right and you work with someone who
knows what they're doing it's a bloody
pleasure
they tell you what they're going to do
they tell you how much it will cost
they go and do it it works and you pay
them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence
and so you listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people
it's not such a terrible thing man maybe
you wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible
most people aren't but that doesn't mean
there isn't something you could be great
at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top
you know flap about uselessly and whine
about your life
it's not helpful it'll just make you
miserable you're not reliable
to anyone you can't help out in a crisis
it's like
so you tell young people and this is
another message for conservatives like
i don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for god's sake be an honest
person
and work and get to the top of whatever
it is that you want to get to the top of
you know and and and and that stand up
for yourself like a respectable human
being and
be a bit of a light on the world instead
of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's
it's painful to watch they're so
relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself
see if you can learn to tell the truth
concentrate on something for a year or
two
you could be a bloody world beater they
think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting
that might make life for life worth
living it's like yeah it might so
why don't you go do it that's what the
damn universities were supposed to be
teaching people they've forgotten that
i went to harvard a month ago month and
a half i used to teach
there and i talked to a bunch of
students you know and i told them
it's not easy to get into harvard you
know like you're a valedictorian
if you're at harvard and not only are
you a valedictorian
you're way better than most people at at
least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the
acceptance rate is like five percent and
believe me not everybody applies so
it's a very selective school and so why
am i saying that it's like
these are high quality kids so i told
them what i just told you it's like
here you are at harvard it's like get
yourself educated man
read some books learn to talk learn to
think make yourself into something
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here
happy that you were put there in that
great institution
you know and they came up to me
afterwards and said
god i wish someone would have told us
that when we were in our first
year it's like jesus why didn't someone
tell them that
for god's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest university in the world
is it so difficult to figure that out
you don't
tell your kid here's an impossible thing
why don't you go out and fail you say
here's something worth going after
here's a step you could take that would
push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at
right they call that within a time frame
within some time frame that's the other
thing you have to parameterize it with
regards to time frame
that's right and that puts you in the
zone of proximal development and that's
a that's a concept that was generated by
a guy named vygotsky he was a russian
developmental psychologist and a smart
one it's where the idea of the zone
comes from to be in the zone
and when you're in the zone you're
expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding
because you're succeeding and so you
want to set if you're good to yourself
you think okay i need to set a goal
but i need to set a goal that someone as
stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it
then you got then you've got it
perfectly because it's not so high that
it's grandiose or impossible that you
fail necessarily and then justify your
bitterness
it's like well i could do well because
that happens to people happens all the
time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time
frame that's right you didn't calibrate
it properly yeah and and you're playing
a trick on yourself because you wanted
to fail so that you could justify not
having to try
and being a victim yeah which isn't
helpful you're still going to be
a victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so
you know because life is this life is a
challenge that in some sense can't be
surmounted sad to see that people are
disenchanted and nihilistic and
depressed and anxious and aimless and
and perverse and vengeful and and all of
those things it's
terrible and then to see people
question whether that's necessary and
then to start to rise out of it it's
like
it's so fun like last night i was at
after my talk
it's overwhelming
i don't usually think about these things
but i was i was after my talk last night
and so all these people line up and
you know they have their 15 15 seconds
with me and they're kind of tentative
they're excited and attentive when they
come up to talk to me and then they have
you know 15 seconds of time to tell me
something i'm really listening to them
and they're hesitant about whether or
not to share
the good news about their life you know
and i think it's often because
when people share good news about their
life
people don't necessarily respond
positively
you know they don't get encouragement
and people need so
little encouragement it's just
unbelievable
and so they'll tell me something good
and i think god that's so good you know
somebody says oh
i'm getting along way better with my
father i haven't seen him for 10 years
and now we get along it's like
god great and then the power of that you
can't overstate the power of that for
individuals to get their life together
the individual is an
unbelievably powerful force and every
single person
who gets their act together a little bit
has the capacity to spread that around
them
it's it's a chain reaction and so it's a
lovely thing to see
one of the things that's really
interesting about the old testament is
that
and the jews in the old testament is
that they don't take the path of cain
every time they're walloped by god which
is like fairly frequently
they say we must have done something
wrong and we have to set herself right
and that's a an unbelievably heroic
attitude because
that's the alternative to cursing fate
it's like you take the responsibility
for failure onto yourself
and you think well if i was just maybe
if i just had my act together a little
bit more
if i took advantage of every opportunity
that was put in front of me if i wasn't
resentful and bitter
then i could have done something that
would have tilted
the situation in a different direction
and like that's almost inevitably true
dostoevsky i think said something like
every man is responsible for everything
that happens to him and everything that
happens to everyone else
and that's you know that that's that's a
it's a crazy statement right it's a
crazy statement and he was a pretty
extreme person in many many ways but
there's a
level at which that's metaphysically
true you know because
what happens is that it's it's failure
to act often that's the
most catastrophic you know i mean i've
it's it's it's to not do the right thing
when the
when the situation presents itself and
it's very specific you know you're
constantly
in situations where you could do the
right thing
if you were willing to take a risk
that's actually of relatively moderate
size
and you know that you could take the
risk and you know that you should take
the risk and you don't
that happens to people all the time and
then what happens is
the thing that they didn't oppose grows
a little bit
and they shrink a little bit i notice
that there's always a group of
my friends who always criticize what i'm
saying and not even
um try to understand what i'm where i'm
coming from
and um i've i've always wondered how to
deal with that i mean
i want to listen to what they're saying
but
they're not understanding what i'm
they're not trying to listen to what i'm
saying so what would you do in that
situation
very briefly okay there's a line in the
new testament that's relevant to that
do not cast pearls before swine
and what that means is that if people
are not listening to you
stop talking to them and that's really
that is the best piece of advice that i
can give you and what happens is
that if you stop talking to people who
aren't listening to you
and start watching them instead they
will tell you what they're up to
but so if you have things to say say
them but you find people that will
listen
talk to them the ones who aren't
listening pull back
because you're you're devaluing what you
have to say by offering it to an
audience that does nothing but reject it
and that's a good guideline to life in
general so
pull back first of all you have to treat
yourself like you matter
because if you don't then you don't take
care of yourself and you become vengeful
and
and and cruel and you you take you take
it out on people around you and you're
not a positive force
none of that's good so you suffer more
and so does everyone around you and
there's a malevolence that enters into
it
none of that's good so that's what
happens if you don't treat yourself like
you matter
and then what happens if you don't treat
other people like they matter well
you lie to them you cheat them you steal
you
you enter into impulsive relationships
with them they can't trust you
that doesn't go anywhere they don't like
you you end up alone at best and maybe
like incarcerated at worst like that
doesn't work
and so you watch the people around you
who thrive regardless of what they
say they act out the proposition that
everyone matters
and then you have a functional society
and i think okay well if
if if when you act out the proposition
that everyone matters you have a
functional society
maybe that's evidence that that
proposition is true if you're failing
repeatedly
um then there's probably something wrong
it's possible that there's something
wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world because you
have a choice right if if you keep
making sacrifices and they don't work
there's a binary choice and one is well
there's something
wrong with the structure of reality
and the other is there's something wrong
with your approach and so then you might
say well let's take the first idea
there's something wrong with the
structure of reality
it's like you're really going to say
that are you you're really going to come
out and say
i know enough to judge the nature of
being
and and then the alternative is also
quite frightening because then you know
you
it's you that's making the mistakes and
you might be wrong at a really deep
level and that might mean that
a lot of you has to burn off and be
transformed maybe even things about
yourself that you think are admirable
and that you like because your position
you know your
your self conceptualization is so warped
and wrong
and that's really daunting but you know
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being
i mean i've written about this a fair
bit in my new book which is
called 12 rules for life when people set
themselves up as the judge of being then
they take on what can only be described
as a kind of satanic arrogance
because they've actually taken to
themselves the moral right
to criticize the structure of existence
itself it's like you better be careful
when you do something like that
because you're setting yourself up as
the judge of being i like this one and i
think
i mean this is very clearly what you do
be precise in your speech
so in in genesis one of the things god
has adam do first
so god makes the world by speaking okay
so that's the first thing to think about
you're supposed to think like in a
sophisticated way about this
the idea is that there's some integral
relationship between
communication and the structure of being
it's part of the role that consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language takes the chaos and makes it
into
things and so
god has adam name all the animals
they're not even really
real until they have names now
they're more implicit that's another you
know here's a here's an example let's
say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why it's unnameable
is it real
well yeah it's manifesting itself in
like a physiological discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry
thing that's kind of potential it goes
snap
and then it's this thing right and then
that's a horrible thing it's like a
little poisonous thing but it's not a
whole
foggy cloud of potential poison it's
like this little
sharp poison thing and then you think
okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
precision
that specifies and like so this is a
little bit of the voldemort effect right
if since you're a harry potter guy they
wouldn't name it right this is a problem
we gotta name them first
oh yeah you gotta name them first
absolutely because the unnamable is far
more terrifying than the nameable
you see that in there was this great
blair witch project
terrifying movie well it's
unnamed there's nothing terrible happens
in that movie it's all the unnamable
it's like what's going on what's going
on what's going on
and no matter how terrible the actuality
is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination
because your imagination like it's an
old thing it's seen a lot of terrible
things in the history of life like
it can put monsters everywhere and so
it's almost
always better it might be better without
exception
to name the thing no matter how terrible
it is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're
you're telling yourself that you're so
terrified that you can't bring your
attention to bear on it
and that makes you you're the loser
instantly
if it's so terrifying that you cannot
face it
it's what you write in the book there is
no faith
and no courage and no sacrifice in doing
what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and
are locked into their careers because
they're too afraid
to take risks and pursue something
meaningful well the first thing i would
say is
well you should be afraid of taking
risks and pursuing something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that
you get to have any any permanent
security
outside of your ability to contend and
adapt it's the same issue with children
it's like
you're paying a price by sitting there
being miserable you might say well the
devil i know is better than the one i
don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking
yeah and if you're miserable in your job
now and you change nothing in five years
you'll be much more miserable and you'll
be a lot older
but isn't it the luxury to pursue what
is meaningful our viewers have
mortgages they have children yeah they
have payments and loans
it's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources well i don't think i don't
remember now i'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful
and that doesn't mean it's easy it might
require sacrifice
if you need to change your job too let's
say you have uh
family and and and children and a
mortgage you have responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well i don't
like my job i quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my
soul all right so what do i have to do
about that well i have to look for
another job
well no one wants to hire me it's like
okay maybe you need
to educate yourself more maybe you need
to update your your curriculum
vita your resume maybe you need to
overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like
you you have to think about these things
strategically if you're going to switch
careers you have to do it like
an intelligent responsible person that
might take you a couple of years of
of effort to do properly i mean i've
i've
dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and
we set a goal we develop a vision and
work towards it and
it things inevitably get better for
people
so it's not a luxury it's it's difficult
it's a moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness it's
it's not the pursuit isn't for happiness
it's a moral responsibility
to pursue what is meaningful absolutely
us human beings
you know you're not after um the bubbles
of bliss that dostoevsky described in
in notes from underground we're built to
contend with the world we're built to
contend with reality
you want to challenge and the best way
that you can take on a challenge
because a challenge fortifies you so you
don't want to be secure you want to be
strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate
and you make yourself stronger while
you're doing so and you might fail
and fortune might do you in but it's
your best bet
and you know people have also people
that
have extracted unbelievable successes
out of catastrophic failures
and so and i'm not saying that in a
naive way i know perfectly well what
happens to people you know
you're doing fine in life and then you
get cancer and then six months later
you're dead
and all the heroism in the world isn't
going to save you at that point
but that's not the point that's not the
point
life is bounded by mortality but that
doesn't mean that you don't get out
there and contend
and you develop by contending and you
minimize the net amount of suffering in
the world
and that's something man that's
something to do life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children
what you can do is prepare them and you
can prepare them to be strong and
courageous and
truthful and resilient and reciprocal in
their interactions with other people
and that means you equip them for what
life will be which is
at minimum a series of difficult
challenges and and often more than that
because of course people go through very
difficult times in their lives and
a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear
and moving forward voluntarily convinced
of their own
competence and ability to prevail and
so the primary your primary goal as a
parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major
obligation on your part is to encourage
your children and to
and i mean that literally to instill in
them a sense of courage
in the face of the difficulties of life
and not to protect them from that
we don't even want to be protected from
those difficulties because
a major part of life and its meaning is
the
the challenge that comes with
confronting difficulties
the baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time
and so he represents the self from the
union perspective now the self is
everything you could be across time
so imagine that there's you and there's
the potential inside you
whatever that is you know and potential
is an interesting idea because it
represents something that isn't yet real
yet we act like it's real
because people will say to you you
should live up to your potential and
that potential is partly what you could
be
if you interacted with the world in a
manner that would gain you the most
information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment
new genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins
and so you're full of biological
potential that won't be realized unless
you move yourself around in the world
into different challenging circumstances
and that'll turn on different circuits
so it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense
it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands
on on yourself all the way down to the
genetic level
and that manifests new elements of you
and so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point
to somewhere central and that would be
say like the rock in the
pride rock and the lion king because you
take yourself out of your dopey little
village
and that's just the little bounded you
that everyone knows and that isn't very
expanded
and then you go somewhere dark and
dangerous to the central place and while
you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you
like partly because you're becoming
informed
which means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too
my primary motive as a clinical
psychologist and educator is to help
individuals
live more meaningful and productive
lives in harmony with their
families and their community that's my
motive
and the evidence for that i think is
well if people go online and first of
all you can watch the lectures and
decide for yourself but you can also go
there's i suspect probably
maybe 250 000 people have commented on
the lectures and their effects on them
and so that's what people say i'm
watching the lectures
yeah i'm trying to develop a vision for
my life i'm trying to become more
responsible
and it's really helping and that's and
that's
what i hear all the time when i do these
public lectures which which aren't
political
but when we gain success we raise the
bar we
set our ambitions higher i mean what is
your end game what do you want
that's all that's what i want i want i
want to help as many
individuals as possible become more
courageous
more truthful and more engaged in the
pursuit of
individual familial and social harmony
that's what i want you're doing a great
job of modeling courage
in the face of fire well there's
something i'd like to say maybe
in closing about courage people say that
to me and you know i don't think it's
exactly right
there's there's a line in the old
testament the fear of god is the
beginning of wisdom
and i think it's more like that it's not
that i'm courageous it's that i'm afraid
of the right things
so when i made my videos it wasn't like
that didn't make me nervous
but i was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what i had to say
than i was about making the videos
because i know where this is going i
don't want to go there
and so it's it's not so much courage
it's that
it's a matter of i it's it's it's
less risky to say something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said i know
that to be the case and so lots of times
in life it's like
there's no pathway forward that's going
to shield you from risk you get to pick
this risk
or you get to pick this risk and i think
i picked the lesser risk
and that might be wise but i'm not so
sure it's courageous
the more radical the necessary change
the more pain that accompanies it
like the more opportunity as well but
and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully
and so it's not surprising that people
shrink away from learning
we learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that
like the things that really that you
really learned in life it's like it was
no joy man
like it took you out and so the fact
that people flee from that is hardly
surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better the better idea is to
eat a little poison every day so that
you don't have to overdose in a month
it's something like that and it is the
case that
i think because you don't
you aren't forced to first of all you
don't learn unless you're forced to
learn
i know there's alternatives to that
there's the voluntary search for
knowledge
and that's a fine thing and that is an
antidote to this
but apart from that speaking more
practically you tend not to learn unless
you're forced to learn and
it's and what you tend to learn by force
are difficult lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you it's because maybe
it's because they're convinced that
there's some way of forestalling the
necessary learning
and there isn't any way of forestalling
it all you do is make it worse in the
future you make yourself smaller
and you make the lesson harder and so
that's why
in so many religious doctrines there's
emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that you don't know
enough so that your life isn't going to
be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way
you should take it as fast as you can
but you have to have a very
tragic i would say view of reality and
also
a harsh one because it's not just
tragedy it's also malevolence you have
to understand that those are waiting for
you
and that makes you desperate enough to
learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but that's that's a hard way of looking
at the world
so one of the things i've been talking
to my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
um messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it um
you know if you start with the
presumption
that there's a baseline of suffering in
life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering
that's sort of the baseline against
which you have to work and
and and it's contemplation of that often
that
makes people hopeless and depressed and
anxious and overwhelmed and all of that
and
and and they have the reasons but you
need something to put
up against that and what you put up
against that
is meaning meaning is actually the
instinct that helps you guide yourself
through that catastrophe
and most of that meaning is to be found
in the
adoption of responsibility so if you
think for example if you think about the
people that you admire
well you think about when you have a
clear conscience first because that's a
good thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better
yeah that's better guilting yourself
you're not feeling bad about yourself
that's right
you feel that you've justified you've
justified your existence
right and so you're not waking up at
three in the morning in a cold sweat
thinking about all the terrible things
that you've involved yourself in
what you said to someone that you
shouldn't have said or how you acted or
what opportunity you lost or or or yeah
or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and
all of that and so if you think about
the times when you're at peace with
yourself with regards to how you're
conducting yourself in the world it's
almost always
conditions under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least
the most the most guilt i think that you
can experience
perhaps is the sure knowledge that
you're not even taking care of yourself
so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people because
that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life
and that that characterizes a very small
minority of people
and an even smaller minority think
that's justifiable
but most of the time you're in guilt and
shame because you're not
you're you're not not only are you not
taking care of yourself let's say so
someone else has to
but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a
existential weight that goes along with
that people came to my website because
they were
interested in well before the political
stuff blew up i had a million views on
youtube which is
nothing a million of anything is a lot
but then when the political scandal
started to break yeah then people came
for them but stayed for the content and
so and that's been really useful
yeah well it's all well and it's not
that surprising well you know because of
what you do it's like
there's a great hunger for information
that
is practical and useful and
that helps people find meaning in their
lives and orient themselves there's a
great hunger for that and
most of my lectures were derived from
solid psychology some of it experimental
some of it biological
some of it from from from the domains of
neuroscience
a lot of it from great clinicians it's
not surprising that people find it
helpful because
well great clinicians were great because
they were really helpful and so to
distill that and to offer it to people
in a digestible form
to have that have a good effect on them
well that's that's what you'd expect
that's what the whole discipline is
about
our topic is the rising tide
of compelled speech in canada
[Music]
is
where is security
that's pure narcissism at work by the
[Applause]
way
[Applause]
you know to hijack to hijack an event
like this
that other people put time and effort
into and to
use they their their civility of the
crowd and the civility of the organizers
as an excuse to blatantly yell out your
ill-informed opinions there's no way to
conduct a civil dialogue it's absolutely
appalling the people who do that should
be embarrassed
these people are not your friends
let me see you know that's
that that and mark my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates
right
yeah that's all i'll tell you again too
that use of in kuwait
[Music]
what would you call it in kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of
their argument
and there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you
so keep that in mind it's not amusing
there's nothing to it there's nothing
for it the thing that's also quite
appalling is that
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
people who are conducting these protests
know what it is that they're protesting
against
you know i was in
[Applause]
[Music]
i i i was in the midst of a discussion
attempting to make the case that
it's freedom of speech that's that is
what people who have nothing still have
right so if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society let's say the
people at the top have
access to means of communication
everyone knows that
it's the people at the bottom who have
the right to say what they think
however badly they say it that enables
them to get a toehold into the system
and to
and to make their suffering known that's
what freedom of speech is for
and so like what's the protest against
that and i'll tell you you know
that the radical neo-marxist types they
speak the language of power
and that's what they're speaking right
now and if you want to live in a world
where everyone speaks the language of
power then
just let them do what they're doing and
see what happens
i wouldn't recommend it it's not a
pretty road and you're all
in a position you're on a situation in
your life now where you have to make
decisions about this sorts of things
like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be
the idea that in some sense you're an
eternal victim
well there's a truth in that given that
nature is conspiring to destroy you and
will be successful in the end
that you're undermined by your own
society at the same time you're
buttressed by it
and that you're a target of your own
malevolence and that of others
i mean so there's plenty there's there's
a triad of
tragic and malevolent forces that are
aimed directly at your heart
and that's always the case but
but to not take responsibility for that
and to attribute
attribute to that to a cosmic injustice
or a
sociological injustice in some sense
that's aimed particularly
you that's somehow the fault of others
is to miss the great adventure of your
life in that
adoption of that adventurous mode of
being there's a deep meaning to be found
right a meaning maybe that transcends
just you that involves your family and
that involves your community and
maybe even the destiny of humanity
itself
but there's nothing about that that's
secure or easy and very little
that has to do with happiness the
the idea that your problems should be
solved for you
let's say and that it's unfair that you
have them
well it it it's attractive in that
there's nothing for you to do
except complain but
but it's horrifying in that there's
nothing for you to do
except complain the difficulty is
actually
the funny thing is is the difficulty is
actually the destiny
and it is insanely difficult but
maybe you're insanely up to the task
i've watched people do very difficult
things like people who work in
palliative care awards
so all they're ever dealing with is pain
and death right and they can do it
they get up in the morning they go to
work and they take care of those people
they lose people on a weekly basis and
yet they can do it
and what that shows is that if you turn
around and you confront the suffering
voluntarily
you find out that you are way tougher
than you think it's not that
life is better than you think life is as
harsh as you think
it might even be worse but you are way
tougher than you think
if you turn around and confront it and
so then what you discover is that
there's a spirit within you that
pursues some that can pursue something
meaningful that has the
resilience and the strength to contend
properly with the catastrophe of
existence without becoming bitter
that's actually the central so and then
i would say that's one of the central
themes of 12 rules for life is that
make no mistake about it like the first
noble truth of buddhism
life is suffering this is true and it's
worse than that because it's suffering
contaminated by malevolence that's the
baseline but
and so that's very pessimistic but the
optimistic part is that
you are so damn tough you can actually
not only deal with that you can improve
it
it's like oh well that's a horrible
situation
but it turns out that i'm armed for the
task well that's
that's a great thing for people to know
and i do believe i think the fact that
we're armed for the task is even more
true
than the fact that life is catastrophe
contaminated by malevolence
we're stronger than things are terrible
so and things are pretty terrible
so that means we're pretty damn strong
wow yes it's a very good thing to know
and it's not naive optimism it's a very
different thing it's like no
things are terrible they're brutal and
you are so damn tough
you can't believe it if you don't have a
goal
a transcendent goal say something that's
beyond you
then you don't have any positive emotion
and that's
not good because you have plenty of
negative emotion
and then that's that's the problem with
fundamental claims of meaninglessness
too in life that it's this
it's the philosophical error that's made
by nihilists
let's say who say well life is
meaningless it's like well
if you're a nihilist genu genuinely
you've lost all
hope your life isn't meaningless it's
just
unbearably miserable and that's
and that's a form of meaning you know
that suffering is a form of meaning
and you can try to argue yourself out of
that with your nihilistic
rationalizations
but that is not going to work you need
a transcendent goal in order to
withstand
the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune
values aren't created they're discovered
and they're discovered through
a consultation with the parts of
yourself that you're not conscious of
that you're not fully conscious of that
aren't articulated
that aren't fully articulated elements
of your primary personality
you have to discover what your values
are
and you're informed about that well
partly by other people who will object
if your values aren't appropriate but
certainly by a dialogue with yourself
and with your conscience
that's that's a very important thing to
know it's part of the reason why i think
that you need to tell the truth
because
you're forced to negotiate with yourself
to operate properly in the world and if
you've warped yourself
let's say or some elements of yourself
by engaging in self-deception and lies
and and you're not now because of that
you're not who you could be and you
don't live in the world
as you should live in it then when you
discuss with yourself
what your value should be it will be as
if you're discussing it with someone
that you can't trust
and that's that's not good like
you you can't afford that life is
difficult and it contains many pitfalls
and
unless you're careful and you sort
yourself out properly and you
aim high and walk on the straight narrow
path
you don't have a hope of understanding
where you should be and at what time
when
the crisis hits you love to quote this
line this nietzsche line that um
anyone who has a y to live for can
endure almost anyhow
what's your why what is driving you see
when people read history they
they either read it as a detached
observer or they tend to read it as
well maybe the heroic the heroic
protagonist
people like to imagine that they would
be schindler
in schindler's list but that's wrong
so because the probability that you'll
be the perpetrator is much higher
especially
merely the perpetrator who's in constant
silence when silence is not the
appropriate thing
so i wanted to having figured out what
constituted hell and the pathway to that
which would be
i suppose the cowardice that produces
the cowardice and resentment that
produces either complicitness
in those events or failure to
oppose them when they emerge i wanted to
understand what the opposite of that was
because i think that's what needs to be
learned from what happened in the 20th
century and so that's why i wrote maps
of meaning was to
understand that and to lay out what the
opposite was
and then that turned out to be extremely
helpful to me and
then to the people i started to teach
about that because
it's useful to know what the opposite of
hell is
and i've been teaching those things to
people
since 1993 such 25 years and
the response from the students has
always been the same sort of response
that i'm getting now
um absent some of the negative uh
characterizations let's say
which which have emerged for for
particular reasons but the students have
always said one of two things
and and this is the vast majority of
them this isn't cherry picked
responses it's been the same everywhere
um
they tell me and this is the same
response i get from my audiences now too
is
they say you've given me words to
explain
things to explain and understand things
that i always knew to be true
or i was in a very dark place for one of
the seven reasons that
people might be in a dark place alcohol
or drugs or
failure of relationships or lack of
vision or nihilism or
or hopelessness or depression or anxiety
and all the
pitfalls that people can encounter and
i've been
developing a vision for my life and
trying to adopt responsibility and
trying to be careful with what i say
and things are way better and that's
what drives me
what's your definition of greatness well
greatness is what reveals itself when
you
when you attempt to formulate when you
attempt to
carefully articulate and live out what
you believe to be true
it just happens because there isn't
anything more powerful than truth
right that's the antidote to suffering
truth
right so it's a strange thing because
you think well yeah it produces a lot of
suffering too it's like
yeah in the short term they say do you
believe in god let's say
and my response to that always is well i
don't know what you mean when you ask me
that question so i don't know how to
answer it i don't know what you mean by
believe
but i can tell you something that i
believe and i would say this is a
way of speaking symbolically i do
believe
so i was thinking the other day a week
ago i was thinking about
this this little fantasy that entered my
mind i was thinking about saint joseph's
oratorio in montreal
and saint joseph's oratorio is a very
large religious building it's one of the
biggest
cathedral-like structures in the world
and it's set on the hill on mount
royal and it's set up where it can catch
the sun you know so it's an image of the
heavenly city on the hill right
it's an image of the structures that we
strive to create
that's what it is independent of its
specifically christian or religious
function
that's what it stands for symbolically
okay so it's the city on the hill it's
it's what we're striving towards when we
walk uphill
in life okay now the way the the
oratorio is structured there's
hundreds of steps leading to it up front
and in the early part of the 20th
century a lot of people who had physical
disabilities came there
and they struggled up the step on their
crutches and many of them left their
crutches in the oratorio you can see
hundreds of them if you go there it's
quite an interesting site
and i was thinking about that and i was
thinking about what that meant and
this is what it means it means that you
know
everyone has their disabilities let's
say and i know that some people are far
more
terribly affected than other people i'm
perfectly aware of that
but the question is what do you do about
that and what you do is you
you set yourself up on your damn
crutches and you struggle
up the bloody hill that's what you do
and you struggle up the hill towards the
kingdom of god
that's what you do because the
alternative is to descend into the abyss
that's the alternative and then so to
say well do you believe it's like i
believe that you should struggle uphill
towards the city of god on your crutches
that's what you should do that's the
opposite of the descent into the abyss
and so that's that's at the foundation
of our civilization that idea
well argue with it if you will see if
you can figure out why that's not an
acceptable idea
maybe you should help someone struggle
up the hill perhaps you should
you know you can lend a hand to someone
although you don't want to take the
burden away from them entirely because
there's something noble about struggling
up the damn hill right there's something
that's adventure that's the call to
proper being it's like well we don't
need to forget this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there
since time immemorial to try to push
that idea forward through the
generations
and everyone needs to know that idea
that's what gives your life
not happiness forget about that if it
comes well
great accept it dignity nobility
character truth responsibility beauty
those are the things to aim for now and
i've had journalists say well
what makes you think that your right to
free speech trumps the right of someone
to not be offended
and i think that's really the level of
our political discourse okay so we'll
run a little thought experiment so
i'm talking to one person i'm talking to
you and the rule is i don't get to
offend you
okay maybe we can still have a
discussion about something difficult
but let's say i'm talking to 10 people
and about an important thing
now i have to make sure that i don't say
anything to fight despite the fact that
this is an important and contentious
issue that i don't say anything that
offends even one of those 10 people
okay maybe i can even manage that what
if i'm talking to a thousand people
there's going to be someone in that
thousand people there's gonna be someone
who's offended at the mere fact that i
exist
so it's an impossible standard it's like
well you can't say anything offensive
okay fine then you can't say
anything okay so
what you don't get to say anything
because no one should be offended
well then you don't get to think well
what happens if you don't think
well then you can't negotiate your way
through the future
and you fall into a pit and so does
everyone else
so that's where that all ends up you
can't say offensive things
equals you cannot negotiate your way
properly through the future
equals everyone suffers
well that's a bad
that's a bad strategy so and it's
and it's all covered up with well you
know it'd be better if no one was ever
offended
it's like well who thinks that
you know how naive you have to be to
think that you have to be pathologically
naive which is the kind of naive that
you could have grown out of but you
willfully refused to
because you weren't willing to see what
was in front of your face
and then you imposed that blind naivety
on everyone else
because you don't want to allow them to
upset your
like rosy view your rosy view of
yourself and the world
there's it's just there's no
end to how terrible that is i made a
decision when the computers
started to become omnipresent and so
that would have been about 1993
that i was going to spend a year and
that was the first year that i was
teaching in boston
pretty much doing nothing but figuring
out how
intel 486s worked and it meant there was
a lot of other things that i had to put
on hold but
i did become a competent computer user
and i was
i'm pretty fast but you know my son
it's just annoying as hell to watch him
on the computer and on the phone because
and my graduate students as well because
they're so much faster than me that it's
not even funny and
i'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room
and so
[Laughter]
you know you know if i had children now
the one thing i would bloody well make
sure that they knew was how to use a
computer how to program man
because if you're smart and you can use
a computer you are
so much smarter than you are if you're
just smart that it's not even funny
you know when you talk to people you see
this in silicon valley all the time you
talk to people who are expert computer
users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief
so and that that's going to do nothing
but expand right because moore's law is
not dead and
computers are doubling in power every 18
months and
and so and who the hell knows where
that's going to go
the world this way you can think about
it as your orderly little plan
that's a place and you can think about
it as the place that things that disrupt
your plan comes from
that's another place this is a bigger
place than this
because there's an endless number of
things that can disrupt your plan and
only a tiny number of them that can
you know that will help you work it out
so part of the question then too is like
are you the friend of your plan or are
you the friend of the thing that
disrupts your plan
and i would say you should work to
become the friend of the thing that
disrupts
your plan because there's a lot of that
and then if you become the friend of the
thing that disrupts your plan
then you you start to develop strength
in proportion to the
to the disruptive force and that's
really what you want you want to be able
to implement your plan obviously but you
want to be able to
take on the consequences of error
and learn from it and then then you win
constantly because even if something
goes sideways
you think there's something to be
derived from this
that's wisdom fundamentally
conscientiousness is a plan of life
you'd like to have
and and you do that partly by referring
to social norms that's more or less
rescuing your father from the belly of
the whale but the way
other way you do that is by having a
little conversation with yourself
about as if you don't really know who
you are because you know what you're
like you won't do what you're told you
won't do what you tell yourself to do
you must have noticed that it's like
you're a bad employee
and a worse boss and both of those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but but you know
what my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with and that's
and you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life to
and that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much
so you know they're always like cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and it's like god
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time
i don't know what percentage of human
effort is spent
in counterproductive activity you know i
i'm
i'm not an absolute cynic about that but
i mean when i talk to undergraduates i
ask them
you know how much time do you waste
every day
by your own recording and
it's somewhere between five and eight
hours you know it's a lot of
it's a lot of time well i usually walk
through i walk the
students through an economic analysis of
that i said well you know why don't you
value
your time at 50 an hour and calculate
for yourself
just exactly what you're doing to your
future by your inability to discipline
yourself it's worth thinking through
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious industrious is
discipline yourself
and so what do you do with that eat
three times a day at regular meal times
that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time
i would highly recommend all those young
people out there who are listening like
you want to get a jump on life get the
hell out of bed in the morning
you know as i've got older i've got up
earlier and earlier now that's partly
because
you don't need as much sleep but it's
also partly because i've got more and
more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done
man learn to get up at six in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature
especially if you can get to work you'll
have half your damn
day done by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed
and so that's a massive massive
advantage look
will ferrell warren farrell not the
comedian
warren farrell the author he outlined
data in why men earn more which is a
book i would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40
more money it's non-linear so you think
why is that well imagine you had 10
employees
and one of them works an extra 10
percent it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like
45 minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion
obviously right so these tie these small
edges that you can
manage like that work an extra 10
percent
extra 13 have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the
pareto distribution so
get get your sleep cycle organized so
you get up in the morning learn how to
do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings
who cares that's not relevant it's like
discipline yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar
okay a calendar is not a prison and it's
not a tyrant
not if you use it properly a calendar
keeps anxiety at bay
it makes sure that you do what you need
to do which is important because
otherwise you fall behind but if you use
it properly though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and design the days you would like to
have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do
and that would be good for you and
that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious make
a plan you need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months
you need to plan for the next three
months you need a plan for the week
you need a plan for the day you need to
plan for the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now i can't look out more
than about six months
you know because my life is too
complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could
have three to five years out you can't
go much farther than that because life
is too
unpredictable i think to make vision
that's longer term than that subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases
you can have a 10-year goal but it has
to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and
what because what are you going to do
you're going to stumble around and get
get what you need
you're going to stumble around and be
useful to other people and it's useful
to be useful to other people you know
they want to work with you then they
want to do things with you they want to
have you around they trust you they open
up opportunities for you
and if you stumble around like you're
blind you're not going to get anywhere
and then you're going to suffer and then
you're going to be bitter and then
you're going to be cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome
before before you can be a painter who
can paint
what's beyond mere memory you you have
to inculcate that discipline skill and
a lot of that is painful repetition
and hard grinding work it's the
sacrifice of the present for the future
but once you manage that then things
open up and
virtually everything you learn of value
is like that's very
very very difficult to learn to write
and there's arbitrary
arbitrary rules that you have to follow
and bind yourself to
and while you're learning those rules
the probability that you have any
creative freedom to speak of
or any facility with the rules is very
low you're
you're a rank beginner and and even to
some degree whatever creativity you have
is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole
but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side
and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions
universities are exactly that is there
places of guidance
and and there are places to encourage
people to develop the discipline that's
necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines
right i mean the words aren't there by
accident you have to narrow yourself
first and then you can broaden outward
and so that's
and that's part of the process of
maturation that part of the
that's part of the sacrifice of
childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it
and so then the question is well how do
you get to a point where you realize the
potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction
this is nietzsche's commentary on the
catholic church he's a great admirer of
the catholic church despite the fact
that he was also a radical
critic critic of christianity said the
cat
see the thing about the catholic church
is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory
framework and that was a discipline and
once that discipline was established
then
the disciplined mind could explode in
every direction which is precisely what
happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that
when you're a teenager and a young adult
you have to sacrifice
everything you could have been as a
child to be the one
thing that you're aiming at but then
that opens up and and the universities
are part and parcel of that process
and you need the guidance because the
the
the library is too large to wander
through it unneeded
when i was a teenager i mean i i did
god if i had to write a book about the
stupid things i did when i was a
teenager
it'd be a very thick book and it'd be a
worse book if there were photographs
accompanying it
um and you know but
but i had this advantage that young
people today don't have which was
well when my day of stupidity was over
i could go home and it was not there
you know like it wasn't on twitter it
wasn't on facebook
there wasn't 20 of my friends
communicating to me about you know what
foolish thing i did at the party the
night before and
um and young people now they're just
followed by paparazzi
essentially constantly and and i've
watched that with
the young teenage daughters of many of
my friends
uh because my kids were a little too old
for that to have actually have happened
to them but
god it's miserable and um we know that
there is some relationship between the
amount of time people use facebook for
example and their mental health
which me the more they use facebook the
more depressed they are
and it might be that the depression is
driving the facebook use but
the causal pathway seems to be the other
way around which is
you know it's just playing that
unbelievably exposed social game
that's hard on people and these aren't
trivial technologies you know
i mean they're sha they're they're
transforming the way we communicate with
one another and that's
and they're they're completely
uncontrolled experiments we have no idea
what the
medium or long-term consequences are
going to be and we'll never find out
either because
of course the communication landscape
changes so quickly that
by the time you get adapted to one
communication technology another one has
come along
that's even more confusing that you now
have to master
and so well that's why it's necessary
for everyone to develop
their own modicum of wisdom i believe
because
i i don't know how else we're going to
be able to deal with this
technological transformation that's
going to come acro
is already coming across us like a tidal
wave and you know you ain't seen nothing
yet
the other people in silicon valley have
plans that
well that that make you think that the
whole place should probably be bombed
just for the safety of the rest of us
you know because there's there's
tremendous danger in that
rapid acceleration of machine
intelligence and and
we have no we have absolutely no idea
where that's headed
so and maybe it'll be great it's it's
possible it'll be great
but power cuts both ways
so hopefully we can we can
control it with our wisdom and that's
pretty much up to each of you
to put your lives together so you can
make good decisions
you can learn to kind of watch yourself
like you're watching a stranger
but you have to adopt a position it's a
position of radical humility i would say
both both humility in two senses
so one sense would be the humility of
recognizing your ignorance so you have
to understand that you don't know who
you are
and that's not easy to understand
because you think you know but then you
know
you remember you can't control yourself
very well you're not very disciplined
you're full of flaws
maybe you don't know yourself as well as
you think
but it's hard to get low enough
to understand how deeply
it is the case that you are ignorant
about who you are
now there's an upside to that too which
also is that you're also ignorant about
who you could be
and so the discovery of that you know is
some reward for the horror of
determining who you actually
are people can tolerate inequality so to
speak
or even revel in it
let's say if they believe that the
unequal outcome is deserved
i mean look at how people respond to
sports heroes
you know everyone no one goes to a
sports event and booze
the star even though he or she
is paid much better and
attracts the lion's share of the
attention hopefully not into
narcissistic manner people can celebrate
success but they do have to believe that
the game is fair and and and and the
game needs to be fair because otherwise
the hierarchy becomes tyrannical
you know silicon valley tends to be
liberal every everyone knows that and
the reason for that is that there's a
tremendous number of entrepreneurs there
and entrepreneurs tend to be high in
openness and lower in conscientiousness
so they're creative
but they're also willing to break rules
you know which you kind of have to do
often hopefully not to a criminal extent
but you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because
look at a company like uber you know
they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just kind of went ahead and did it
it's not something an orderly person
would do because they'd ask for
permission whereas the people who
started these scooter rental companies
just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but
you know you have to have a
rule-breaking proclivity
in order to manage that take a bit of a
look at yourself and think
about what's not so good that you could
improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this
stack of paper there you know and you
haven't looked at that damn stack for
like a month
and you know that you should be and
you're bothering yourself at night
because you're avoiding that
it's like maybe think i've avoided that
stack of paper completely for one month
i'm quite a coward when it comes to
whatever snakes might be hidden in that
stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like i glance through it for
15 seconds see if i can do that
it's like well you set yourself a goal
of improvement you know it's a humble
goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is
15 seconds of exposure to a stack of
paper
you know it could easily be you've been
avoiding it you're obviously afraid of
it and so the situation could be that
dismal and dire
and you might think well geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no it's
it's no it's not fostering the strength
of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of
and so that's a form of humility too
it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction
and then the question is are you big
enough to take those small
steps you know are you capable of
grappling with the fact that your
fundamentally flawed to the point where
you have to break things down into
almost child-like steps
in order to manage them and the answer
to that is yeah you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner
it's through slow incremental
improvement and then
you challenge yourself it's like well
could i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out
generally you get better at it and you
can take on larger and larger challenges
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are
they also act counterproductively a lot
of the time
regardless we do make progress and and
and we can thrive
under the difficult conditions that make
up our lives and we can
resist the malevolence that entices us
that's within our power and we don't
know the limits to that
and we also know that it's better
to we all know this
that it's better to live courageously
than cowardly everyone knows that
that's what you teach people that you
love
and and
and we know that it's better to live
truthfully than in deceit
and you can tell that too because that's
also what you tell people that you love
and we know that you should
pick up your responsibility and
move forward everyone knows that it's
it's part of our intrinsic
moral nature
and that nature is there and it's not
difficult to communicate to people about
this like
everyone knows that you wake up at three
in the morning when you've
left let your life go off the rails and
that
you berate yourself for your uselessness
and your cruelty and your failure to
take off
to take the opportunities that are in
front of you and if you were
the master in your own house in some
sense
the captain of your own destiny if there
was no intrinsic nature well
that would never happen you'd just let
yourself off the hook
there'd be no voice of conscience
tormenting you
but no one escapes from that and what
that indicates
to me is that at least psychologically
we live in a universe that's
characterized by a moral dimension and
we understand that well and that
moral failings have consequences
and that they're not trivial they
destroy you
they destroy your family they destroy
your community
and and you can tell people that
and they listen because they know they
don't know they know
that's the thing and maybe that's the
thing about being an
intellectual you have the opportunity to
articulate
ideas that other people know they embody
but they can't articulate and that's
what people tell me you know they say
well
you help me give words to things that i
always knew to be true but couldn't say
or or they say i've been trying to put
some of your precepts into practice
responsibility being a main one vision
another
honesty i i suppose bringing up the pack
and saying
this is the fun part of doing all of
this fun
as a weak word that it's it's it's a
it's the remarkable part of doing all
this i mean i have people
tell me constantly wherever i go
it's so delightful that you know they're
in a pretty
dark place and they tell me why and
there's plenty of dark places in the
world and they decided well
maybe they were gonna develop a bit of a
vision and take a bit more
responsibility
and start telling the truth and putting
some effort into something
you know we kind of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if i can if i can put this
properly that you have a certain
delightful wonderful positive freedom as
a child and then that's
given up as you approach adulthood but
the truth of the matter is is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic way more people than you
think
and part of that is because no one's
ever really encouraged them
and so the book is in part a matter of
encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself
get the chaos in in in check and then
you can move towards a state that's
freer
because it's discipline first like look
if you're going to become a concert
pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much
grander freedom and so in virtually
every freedom that you have in life
that's true freedom is purchased at the
price of
discipline your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes you go fight a
dragon and it eats you
and if the if you being eaten wasn't a
real possibility
it wouldn't be a real fight and so you
see people like i've seen people
in my clinical practice sometimes i had
one
client in particular who was undergoing
a particularly vicious divorce with
someone who was
really seriously inclined to take him
out
and would do pretty much everything at
her disposal to do so
and i strategized with him for about
three years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much
he got backed into a corner so hard that
i didn't know how to help him anymore
so i would say however that he like he
was a very truthful person throughout
that and one thing he did do
was part of it was a custody battle
and he did manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say
he did manage to establish what i think
was a lasting relationship with his kids
so he might have got enough out of what
he did
to justify it even though the whole
landscape was pretty
awful i think that
not lying is your best bet
but life is hard and people get run over
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to emerge in any obvious
sense
triumphant but if you take the
alternative path
path especially when you're facing
severe tribulations let's say
and you complicate those with deceit you
can be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering
even if you can't overcome it or
transcend it
and that's something you know if you
really want to solve a complicated
problem
maybe you try to solve it a hundred ways
and then you take the best solution
got it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs
this is something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail at producing their creative product
and monetizing it
right so your default position if you're
a creative person is you're going to
fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's
j and it's hard to present it to the
market at the right time
and it's hard to market it like those
things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and eventually
if they're fortunate one of their ideas
happens to
hit the right place at the right time
and so that's also darwinian in some
sense you know you're creating all these
little enterprises that are sort of
alive
they're run by people after all and even
if your idea is good
that doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so
this is partly why persistence and
that's part of conscientiousness is so
useful it's like
you know what are they safe if at first
you failed then try try again and
um and that would probably mean try
something different rather than the same
thing
but persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many
experiments and and you need to know
that the baseline is failure
you know it's important because
otherwise you'll blame that on yourself
i would say for the last 45 years we've
told
psychologists have been have been
certainly to blame for this at least in
part
you're okay the way you are that's what
we tell young people oh you're okay the
way you are
it's like and there's nothing worse than
you can tell
that you can tell someone who's young
than that especially if they're
miserable
you know and lots of them well if
they're miserable and aimless it's like
oh i'm miserable and aimless and
sometimes i'm suicidal and i'm
nihilistic and i don't have any
direction in your life it's
in my life it's like well you're okay
the way you are here
and it's like they don't want to hear
that they want to hear
look you know you're and you know this
you're useless you know
nothing you haven't got started you've
got
60 years to put yourself together and
god
only knows what you could become
and that's so that message is so much
more
it's so funny because it's so it's such
an attack
but it's so positive because there's
faith there in the
in the potential that makes up the
person rather than the miserable
actuality that happens to be manifesting
itself at the moment
and young people respond extraordinarily
well to that
because when you know that if you're a
parent and you love your
your child your son your daughter what
you're trying to
foster is the best in them
you want that to manifest itself across
the course of their life you want them
to become continually
more than they are to see what they
could be
and well and i think that's part of the
great message of the west is that that's
that's the
that's the ethical requirement of
individual
being in in in the proper sense is to
constantly note that you're not what you
could be
to take responsibility for that and to
and to commit yourself like body and
soul
to the attainment of that ideal you can
look at that pessimism that
that that constitutes let's say the core
of what
well i think it's the core religious
message really is the
is the tragic nature of the world the
reality of
suffering it's it's part of the core
religious message
but what emerges out of that properly
conceptualized is
a remarkable appreciation for what human
beings are capable of
like we are unbelievably
resilient and and able creatures
and we do not have any conception of our
upper limits
you'll discover a little bit more about
your potential as you discover who you
are
especially the darker parts of yourself
because then you discover your potential
for mayhem
there's some real utility in that you
know a discovery that you're dangerous
it's such a useful discovery it's
actually something that strengthens you
because
the first thing that a realization
like that can in fact produce is the
ambition to incorporate that danger into
a higher order personality that
dangerousness into a higher
order personality and that can make you
implacable
i can make you someone who can say no
when you need to say no
you know that can make you someone who
won't avoid necessary conflict and so
that's
as unbelievably useful when you're
moving through life
and you have a plan or a dream and it
shatters
you know someone dies or a relationship
breaks apart or you you have a terrible
upset in your career or you become ill
in some unexpected way
then everything around you falls apart
and you plunge into a
well you plunge into a chaotic
underworld the belly of the way that's
exactly right yes exactly that
and then maybe you stay there because it
isn't necessarily the case that people
get out you know people die
people are in despair permanently but
frequently
something tragic and terrible befalls
you
and you fall apart and you learn
something profound as a consequence and
you put yourself back together and when
you come back out
you're more than you were when you went
in and that's happening in
at a small scale every time you learn
something you know you if you ever
really learn something
it's usually painful it usually means
that you have to recognize
that you're wrong in some important way
you have to let that part of you that's
wrong die
and then you have to let a new part of
you okay so the self
imagine that you undergo a series of
transformations in your life
there are there collapses into the
chaotic underworld and then
many resurrections that happens
continually and that's what molds your
character
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do
to take action on it this week when you
write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down
in the comments below there's another
rule in my book which is rule nine
assume that the person that you're
listening to knows something you don't
well they do the person you're listening
to knows some things you don't
you can be sure of that now whether or
not you can get to them is a different
matter but
if you do get to them it's a real deal
for you that's why you want to listen to
the other person's arguments is because
you're not everything you could be you
don't know the pathway forward with as
much clarity as you could
and it's possible this is one of the
wonderful things that i've had the
privilege of experiencing as a clinician
you know because people it's like i live
inside a dostoevsky novel as a clinician
people come in and they tell me about
their lives and i listen to them and
they tell me things that are just
absolutely beyond belief you know and i
learn
from my clients constantly they're
they're telling me honestly about their
experience they tell me things they
wouldn't tell anyone else because i
actually listen to them
but part of the reason i listen is
because i'm desperate to listen it's
like
there's a possibility i'm going to do
something stupid in the next five years
that's going to be like
fatal and there's some small possibility
that if we have a
decent discussion that you'll tell me
something that will eliminate
some of my blindness so that i don't
have to fall into that particular pit
and if you have a good sensitivity for
the depth of the pit then
you know you're pretty bloody motivated
to avoid it
and so and that and and that that
dialogue is it's
it's dialogic it's dial logos right it's
shared logos it's the way that we redeem
ourselves mutually moving forward if you
want to change your life for free in the
next 30 days check the link right here
below me or if you want jordan peterson
six pieces of life-changing advice check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there